من تحت الارض خذتهب طهران ما بقي من اوراق
على طاوله مفاوضات ملفها النووي تخصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه 60 في المئه في مجمع
فردو يرفع نسبه التوتر اكثر بينها وبين
الوكالات الدوليه للطاقه الذريه واطراف
اتفاق ينفذ انفسه الاخيره بغضب كبير
استقبل الطهران قرار مجلس محافظي الوكاله
الذي يامرها بالتعاون بشكل عاجل مع تحقيق
يستمر منذ شهور ما يجري في فندق هو جزء من
الرد الايراني على قرار الخميس الماضي
بنظر المسؤولين الايراني الخطوه الاخيره
لم تكن مفاجاه للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص
لايران
طريقه عمل ايران عندما يعبر المجتمع
الدولي عن مخاوف حقيقيه بشان برنامجهم
النووي وعن انهم ليسوا شفافين وهم يردون
بالتصعيد
في رساله الاحتجاج التي بعثتها طهران
للوكاله ورد انها ستفعل سلسله جديده من
اجهزه الطرد المركزي في فورد
بموجب اتفاق 2015 وافقت على وقف العمل في
فندق وعدم التجاوز عتبه ثلاثه فاصل 67 في
المئه لتخصيب اليورانيوم بين ان انسحاب
اداره الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب منه دفعها الى التخلي التدريجيا عن
التزاماتها كما توضح جهود الاداره الحاليه
لاحياء الاتفاق وصلت الى طريق مسدود
المفاوضات والمجمده سبتمبر الماضي رغم
اعتقادي وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ان الامل
ضئيل في حل حاله الامور بسبب الاحتجاجات
في ايران الا انه يترك باب الحوار مفتوحا
كما قلنا من قبل واكثر من مره ما زلنا
نؤمن ان افضل وسيله لتجاوز تحديات برنامج
ايران النووي هي الدبلوماسيه ايران
والاسباب متعدده اختارت اقامه قضايا
خارجيه في جهود احياء الاتفاق النووي مع
القوى العالميه
تازمت العلاقه بين طهران والوكاله الدوليه
بعد عصور المفتشين على اثار اليورانيوم في
ثلاثه مواقع غير معلنه وبدا بعدها مسلسل
التقارير والتقارير المضاده بينهما الثابت
فيها اسرار الوكاله على عدم الحصول على
اجابات واضحه وفقدان التعاون المطلوبي
للتحقيق في الامر
يورانيوم فورد العالي النقاء سيخفض نسب اي
تقارب هذه الفتره جمع الوكاله في فيينا بل
القوه الغربيه المعنيه باتفاق النوويه لم
يبقى منه سوا